Kim Kardashian brings mama Kris Jenner
to tears with a nostalgic birthday gift
oh my gosh such a gift Kim had an epic
secret up her sleeve and tricked the
entire Kardashian Jenner crew and a few
of chris's closest friends into thinking
they were going to a birthday lunch at
the Beverly Hills hotel to celebrate
Chris's 64th birthday when in fact she
had rented out their childhood home to
host the lunch there I'm proud of my
kids they did a good job Kim posted
about this special family moment on
Twitter writing quote all of our
memories live here especially with our
dad it's where each Kardashian child was
born and made us who we are
growing up the home had the most
ridiculous wallpaper in kitchen set I
remade all of our table settings out of
the same fabric imprint as a wallpaper
when one of us does something this
special it's just not even a you know
what we're there we're gonna show up for
each other because that's what we do and
the kids were I was so proud of all my
girls
the reality star also remade her mom's
old car with the exact license plate yes
you're reading that right it says to die
for sorry
Kim reflected on the memorable day via
Twitter writing this was the most
special nostalgic day of my life and we
felt my dad's presence and joined this
day with us I kept it together at lunch
even though I cried during the planning
process but at the end I went into my
old bathroom close the door and cried so
hard
[Music]